welcome back to the rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse and our infinity Saga rewatch
reveals something we missed about the
timeline of Thor in his toys
specifically Mele near Saturn
Ragnarok replaced with a poorly aimed
battle ax resurrected an endgame
shared with friends and next it appears
in the hands of Jane Foster in the
upcoming Thor love and thunder currently
scheduled for February 2022 which is uh
not just because we think the world
might still be there by then and not
just because we thought Jane Foster with
lavon solely and that one file photo
Marvel has of her but because that
weapon was supposedly returned to its
past timeline at the end of endgame and
it's not like there's a backup Mjolnir
lying around in the president MCU
timeline or is there one lying around
based on visual clues I'm ashamed to say
I initially overlooked I think we may
actually now know how me only err could
end up in the Thor 4 and what that
hammers journey tells us about the love
and thunder plot so lets forensic ly
break down the timeline of jane's future
murder weapon thor wielded this thing
his whole life well aside from a few
days in new mexico and that brief moment
cap nudged it and when vision burrowed
it and when the coffee table and the
wall hook proved themselves worthy and
oh yeah hella carried it as her major
weapon for centuries before Odin
banished her and lied about her
existence father of the year besides all
those this was all time for possession
hell is past possession allowed her to
crack it like an egg
leaving shards of you on a cliffside for
Norwegian kids to play down their
annoying siblings Thor of course got his
new weapon from a tree and the Valier in
infinity war Stormbreaker forged from a
roof heated by a dying star but here is
what we missed though all that multi new
roof load into the storm breaker Forge
you can see a secondary guru flow into
an additional porch that secondary Forge
isn't the back half of Stormbreaker it's
probably not the handle I didn't really
have time to go into this in my Infinity
Ward breakdown other than to joke that a
tree could be printing personal projects
he's in the company ink just let me
forge myself new hands I'm all alone
here and a hand is a Dwarfs best friend
but hold on to that thought not what a
treat does in his spare time but the
secondary Forge mystery as we move on
with our timeline because this is all
important and we know Stormbreaker gave
Thor the power of the Bifrost also the
ability to withstand a blast of all six
Infinity stones combined but it looked
at one key thing Odin's worthiness charm
this from the end game final battle
Thanos was able to catch Stormbreaker by
the handle lift it upward wield it
whereas with mill near he could not
wield it he had to grab cat by the wrist
because he could not hold mule near
himself this worthiness charm stayed
intact after a Thor went back in time to
2013 and he summoned that meal here from
that time line now I actually timed out
where past Thor would have been at that
moment the good mimic Thor might have
been jumping off that balcony expecting
to catch meal here but then he would
have rude heed to the ground below who
you looking for this but actually
running these at the same time future
Thor and rocket past Loki as he was
tossing his Cup in a Cell which was
right before cursed broke out in dark
worlds and that is when Thor jumped off
and then after that is when Frigga
scored a Jane to safety which an endgame
is when a future Thor runs into her and
in the dark world Thor doesn't come back
up to the ground level until after we
see Frigga back in the chamber with Jane
so this means past Thor would have had
me all near snatched from him while he
was in the middle of that dungeon fight
which you know would have been awkward
we would but you know then again when
Malekith ran into Jane there would have
been no ether sludge to suck out of her
because that Westley when it took it
whatever confusion ensued would have
been erased from existence wind cap
returned meal near in the reality stone
at the end of endgame presumably cap
could have snuck back into Jane's
chamber and then re exposed her to the
ether and felt real bad about doing that
but then left mule near anywhere for
past Thor to summon back to him and pass
the Horde probably would make sure to
keep that weave remote strapped around
his wrist from now on but that brings us
back to Thor at the end of endgame we
last saw Stormbreaker in the take and
knee deleted scene his line in the
background though when Thor drops his
duffel bag in the Benatar makes his
heavy thud suggesting the battle axe was
in there along with cases of Asgardian
ale probably but as we learn a Ragnarok
Thor is carrying the odinforce inside
him he's eager to share whatever power
he has he handed over his rightful rule
of new Asgard Valkyrie as he left with
the guardians of the galaxy
boom people need a king no they already
have one and Thor's even thrilled to
share his worthiness with cap
right though he does prefer Stormbreaker
to mule near give me that you have a
little while
I expect that power-sharing to continue
in Thor 4 hey look you know it's really
hard to know any of this stuff but
sometimes discretion is the name of the
game like when you're trying to carry a
discrete front pocket wallet like one
from the ridge thanks to the ridge for
sponsoring this episode the ridge helps
you carry what you need every day from
their flagship Ridge wallet to portable
charging commuter backpacks they want
you to make the most out of what you're
bringing with you the ridge wallet is
made out of military-grade materials
like titanium and carbon fiber it has a
clean stylish design its chainsaw crew
there's probably easier ways to get into
a wallet than with a chainsaw but you
never know this is their aluminum tiki
design they do have some other colors
and including some sleek black titanium
ones it's light it's strong you're gonna
feel like a new person carrying this
around trust me and they make it easy to
buy with free shipping and free returns
in a lifetime guarantee
it's got 30,000 five-star reviews so you
know they're doing something right they
also have great backpacks and travel
bags RFID blocking pockets and optional
device charging batteries get 10% off
today with free worldwide shipping in
returns by going to Ridge comm slash new
rock stars
that's Ridge comm slash new rock stars
and use the code new rock stars find the
link of the video's description okay
fourth or poor director checked with GT
has confirmed that Jane Foster will
become the Mighty Thor though that there
will be to Thor's Jane and Thor together
Tyga's facing the story on Jason Erin's
the Mighty Thor comics in which Thor has
become unworthy of Milne ear drops it
for good and the hammer begins to
telepathically call out to Jane who at
this time is fighting cancer each time
she we have to be on the air she powers
up into the goddess of thunder and
fights in the war the realms against
Malachy but then when she returns to
normal her chemotherapy is reset based
on the proper use at comic-con last
summer the weapon Jane will wield is the
only ER not Stormbreaker Thor will
likely continue to wield bats so she's
gonna get her hands on me linear somehow
which brings us back to a tree's back up
Forge we clearly saw them bust that
Stormbreaker mold it can never be made
again as I said the back of boards is
not making the back half of a
Stormbreaker both pieces are in that one
mold it's probably not forging the
handle like you wouldn't make the handle
out of the metal - it should be made of
wood
which is why groots arm was so perfect
for it I believe a tree was secretly
forging a replacement Mjolnir
perhaps he assumed that Stormbreaker
would be a one-time-use weapon justice
light thanasis top the Infinity stones
and that's it it would endure too much
damage to do that and that big blow so
afterwards Thor would probably need his
trusty hammer once more my theory that
love and thunder will open with Jane's
suffering from the residual effects of
once having the reality stone sludge in
her body as Bruce Banner explained the
stones emit gamma radiation powerful
enough to put him in a sling and fry
Tony starts to a crisp
perhaps that exposure to radiation has
left Jane with terminal cancer Thor
would obviously feel pretty guilty about
that so and what he thinks is an act of
kindness Thor grants Jane a way to stave
off her fate a backup meal near forged
by his pal a tree right under our noses
using the odinforce that Thor gained
from his father he enchants this new
mule near with a special kind of charm
like the one his father placed on the
old mule near but rather than one based
on worthiness and thunder one based on
love loves job possess this hammer and
the powers of Thor said bolt was there
too many dwarves and while most of this
movie would show for orange ain't kickin
ass side-by-side I think ultimately Jane
will decide that this life isn't for her
and let go only because I don't see
natalie portman wanting to sign on for a
whole franchise if anything Tessa
Thompson's Valkyrie is the Thor adjacent
hero the franchise wants to follow in
the future and judging from Jo Jo rabbit
hunt for the boulder people Taika
Waititi ittle loves the balances laughs
with one very meaningful and
heartbreaking death of a female
character and guess what's on the other
side of that door Jesus Jesus Jesus he's
tricky like that Jesus spoiler warning
for Jo Jo rabbit even if that female
character is a freakin Avenger and Thor
love and thunder is set up perfectly to
send off Jane Foster and a relationship
with Thor in a powerful way
that evolves both characters it gives
Natalie Portman a role challenging and
media enough to get her to return to
Marvel beyond her of current capacity of
headshots
comment down below with your thoughts on
this theory follow me on instagram at EI
vas falling rock stars in subscriber
breakdowns of everything Marvel thanks
for watching boom
[Music]